well Philippines Nobel Laureate Maria
ressa and her new site rapper have been
acquitted on the charges of tax evasion
what's being viewed as a significant
legal victory for the journalist a Court
ruled that ressa had not avoided paying
taxes on the sale of shares in ratna to
foreign investors former president
Rodrigo duterte had waged a campaign
against rappler calling it a fake news
Outlet sponsored by American spies
well Maria resta joins us live now from
Manila welcome to the program I'll put
simply then how do you feel about this
ruling
uh you know I didn't know how to deal
with last night because I just felt that
this had to be an acquittal given that
this is the fifth of of five tax evasion
charges and we were acquitted of four of
them last January
um thank God it was an acquittal and it
just reminded me my gosh you have to
have faith it took four years and 10
months but we're acquitted rappler and I
are it is as we've said these cases Were
Meant to harass and intimidate us and we
just kept going well indeed you say it's
taken years I mean how challenging have
these
I think this is something Al Jazeera has
covered through the years right in a
little over a year I received 10 arrest
warrants wrappler itself has from 2016
had exponential bottom-up social media
attacks in 2017 our president duterte
attacked us in a state of the nation
address we got our first subpoena about
a week later and then we just kept the
shutdown order happened in 2018 2019 10
arrest warrants right out of those ten
this makes the eighth that is gone so we
have two criminal charges left one of
those has gone all the way to the
Supreme Court this is cyber libel but
the second one has already been uh has
split into two one has been remanded
back to the fiscal so that's almost done
but the one that still hangs
academically sword over us is a civil
case that could lead to our shutdown at
any day so we're kind of out of the
woods but not yet even a vocal critic of
former president uh Rodrigo duterte do
you still feel that your case was
politically motivated even though this
has now come out in your favor
um yeah I'm sorry I didn't hear the last
part but if you're asking whether the
cases are politically motivated we've
maintained this through this time period
uh the attacks that were allied with
both duterte and Marcos this information
networks began in 2016. they were meant
to tear down trust and credibility of
rappler and myself those were followed
these social media time followed by
lawfare just legal cases that drained
our resources and drained our attention
frankly you know I want to quickly read
to you what a rapper's quick statement
which is this this is a victory not just
for rappler but for everyone who has
kept the faith that a free and
responsible press empowers communities
and strengthens democracy we share this
with our colleagues in the industry who
have been besieged by Relentless online
attacks unjust arrests and detentions
and red tagging that have resulted in
physical harm
um we've through a difficult time period
I hope we it is starting the atmosphere
of fear Has Lifted the cases have
started to go away but again as I
pointed out we're not completely out of
the woods yet but we've been tested and
we continue to hold the line and do our
jobs Indeed how does this case resonate
in the Philippines then I mean does this
now set a precedent in terms of of other
journalists
absolutely I mean it shows that doing
the right thing is the right thing and
despite the long period of time it took
resolve the case that you can have faith
that there is a semblance of rule of law
and I think more important than that is
the signal to the business Community
right that that random politically
motivated cases will not come through
will not survive and this is good news
for the international investors that
this Administration hopes to bring in
how does this affect you though
personally what kind of personal toll
does this take
I mean I think if you look at the four
co-founders of rappler we've gotten
duterte agree you know we've we've
weathered a lot a lot of uncertainty but
I would say you know aside from I wrote
a book during this time period aside
from the law fair that we dealt with and
the challenges of being a journalist in
a country like the Philippines you know
you we all face the same challenges
which is technology right because if you
look at the attacks that began against
us it started on American social media
companies on the platforms that connect
us and as as early as 2018 an MIT study
showed that lies spread faster than
facts this is a problem when that
corrupts the entire information
ecosystem so look
um we have a lot of work ahead of us
it's going to be extremely challenging
for news organizations around the world
and we are jumping in to try to find our
way forward and create the journalism
the news organization that we want
we very much appreciate your time here
on Al Jazeera thank you